me dis que bazar vous avez préparé un
cadeau un chronique ah oui mais en fait
c'est un cadeau fait pour vous et rim ça
fait plusieurs fois que vous faites des
mauvaises blagues parce qu'on passe au
fond de votre gentillesse ce grand coeur
tout ça en a marre alors j'ai enquêté
avec vos équipes et à nos ouailles olive
je suis vous habitez est-ce que vous
reconnaissez cette porte à porte là on
l'a 20 ouest
c'est pas très beau ça si oui alors est
aussitôt rentrée alors écoutez on
aimerait bien falloir d'abord d'abord
tâté ferme sas avait d'abord il ya des
gens qui vous aiment dans votre équipe
d'ailleurs eu les clés de chez moi oui
et oui
donc là on va rentrer chez moi
absolument ah oui alors ils vont tomber
alors moi je voulais un possible et
qu'une vraie préparation les chéris mais
c est du coup si je peux récupérer un
caleçon j'avais laissé moi alors les
chéris moi je pense que henry j est ce
qu'on va vraiment rentrer chez moi me
dit que non allez-y matt d'aidé zoomer
dézoomer plus des zooms et triste à dire
qu'on pense qu'on peut avoir un plan
large si vous je sens que c'est aux
[ __ ] sétois alors vous avez vraiment
cru que vous allez m'avoir sécher bien
sûr chez
[Applaudissements]
vous avez fait la ferme célébrités
[Rires]
mathieu on est par ici jamas eh bien
chez vous rêvez teychenné ça va plus et
c'est moi pas là alors on va faire un
petit peu le tour du propriétaire
regarder ya d'autres choses à daisy ce
que tu fais avec autour de la visite de
la visite chez benjamin castaldi
ça va ça diminuerait plaisir de voir
qu'un mail vous savez ce qu'il veut ce
qu'il me ce qui me rend fou ouais c'est
que j'en vois c'est qu'on pourquoi me
fait [ __ ] à chaque fois eh ben voilà
donc c'est chez vous non mais non mais
c'est vrai que ça lombardie mais alors
ça veut dire donc vous mais c'est à dire
que ma femme ma ba oui m'a trahi
non ils votent femme vole vers vous a
trahis mais vous êtes quand même merci à
kamel en tout cas aussi voilà c'était
pas beau benjamin castaldi
[Applaudissements]
sa maman bungie n'a plus que ça chie par
tous ces trucs là vous accomp à tous et
en céréales du parti